Друзі, всім привіт! З огляду на ваші коментарі після серії про класичні види опалення у Німеччині
і численні прохання показати високотехнологічні, нові системи обігріву,
я, звичайно ж, заглибився у цю тему.
Ходити далеко не довелося.
Сучасні сонячні колектори  стоять прямо на даху компанії Deutsche Welle.
Ліземо на дах з головним інженером будівлі DW Торстеном  Дресселем.
Одразу впадають в око громовідводи,
які захищають колектор від блискавки.
Будова колектора дуже проста.
Абсорбуючий шар синього кольору склом закритий від опадів.
Всередині - мідні трубки у вигляді замкнутого контуру,
по якому циркулює рідкий теплоносій.
– Колектор зараз не працює, бо подивіться,
яка погода сьогодні.
- А за умов якої температури він починає працювати?
Температура взагалі не грає ролі, він працює, коли є сонце.
Коли хмарно, він не запускається.
Для нас сезон, коли система працює,
починається у березні-квітні і триває
приблизно до вересня.
Торстен наголошує, що сонячний колектор на Deutsche Welle
використовують для нагріву гарячої води
для потреб кухні, а не для опалення.
Величезний комплекс будівель DW
гріється від центрального опалення.
Цей тип колектора називається "плаский".
Поверхня колектора нахилена під кутом
у 45 градусів у напрямку до сонця.
Для нас вирахуваний оптимальний напрямок – південний захід.
Вартість цієї системи - 100 тисяч євро.
За словами головного інженера, половина витрат пішла на оплату робіт
установки колектора: підняття на дах п’ятиповерхової будівлі
і прокладання усіх комунікацій
на третій поверх підвалу.
Друзі, а обслуговування такої системи коштує
лише 200 євро на рік.
Треба раз на рік вимити поверхню від голубів,
а також випустити повітря із системи.
Спускаємося вниз, щоб подивитися на нижню,
приховану у підвалі частину колектора,
в якій відбувається процес теплообміну
і управління усією системою.
Торстен показує трубопровід, який тягнеться з даху на вісім поверхів униз,
п’ять з них над землею, а три вже нижче рівня землі.
Це наш буферний накопичувач тепла.
І ось цими трубами він з’єднаний з установкою підготовки свіжої гарячої води.
Добре, що в цій установці немає резервуара для попередньої підготовки води.
Гаряча вода утворюється завжди нова завдяки ось цьому теплообміннику.
Гаряча суміш, яка йде з даху, потрапляє у теплообмінник з цього боку,
а з іншого боку теплообмінника
подається питна вода.
У переважній більшості колекторів в ролі теплоносія
використовується незамерзаюча рідина - поліетиленгліколь.
Якщо його у системі не вистачає,
рідину підкачують ось цим синім насосом.
Поліетиленгліколь у теплообміннику нагріває вже чисту воду,
яка подається на кухню Deutsche Welle.
Щоб ми могли побачити, скільки ми виробляємо гарячої води,
у нас є цифровий лічильник.
Загалом ми виробили 31 мегават-годину тепла.
Ще один найбільш розповсюджений вид сонячних колекторів - це вакуумний колектор.
Це фактично вакуумна трубка,
будовою схожа на колбу з термоса.
Тобто дві скляні колби спаяні між собою
і між ними викачане повітря.
На внутрішню трубку нанесений абсорбуючий шар,
який перетворює сонячне світло в тепло.
Для приватних будинків можна придбати
такі невеликі системи
вартістю 3-5 тисяч євро.
Друзі у 2015 році героєм мого першого відеосюжету на Deutsche Welle
був архітектор пасивних будинків
архітектор Кай Кюнцель.
- Вітаю Вас, любі українські глядачі!
І сьогодні пан Кюнцель як спеціаліст із дружніх до довкілля технологій
покаже нам супер-сучасне опалення у гуртожитку для студентів.
Це дітище архітектора Кая Кюнцеля побудоване у 2017 році.
Це  перша у землі Північний-Рейн Вестфалія
п’ятиповерхова житлова будівля з дерева.
Вартість проекту - 3,5 мільйона євро.
Через протипожежні вимоги лише сходи і підвал довелося спорудити з бетону.
Ласкаво просимо до однієї
з найекологічніших будівель у світі!
"Родзинка" цього будинку - опалення повітрям.
Припливно-витяжна вентиляція
з теплообмінником-рекуператором
забезпечує постійну заміну повітря
та запобігає надмірній вологості,
появі цвілі, запахів.
Оболонка будівлі дуже добре ізольована.
Ізоляція з целюлози 30 сантиметрів завтовшки.
І дуже добре, що ось цей концепт, який ми тут побудували,
ми можемо показати студентам.
Відкрита вентиляція має навчальний ефект.
Кожна окрема кімната отримує індивідуально невелику кількість повітря,
необхідну для того, щоб помешкання постійно залишалося свіжим і без запахів,
а надлишкову вологу вентиляція витягує з кімнат.
Сучасна припливно-витяжна установка може залишати в будівлі
тепло використаного повітря.
Тобто фактично це тепло тіл людей, які живуть у будинку,
тепло від приготування їжі та навіть нагрівання комп'ютера чи горіння свічки.
Ось тут два вентилятори: один з них затягує ззовні свіже холодне повітря.
А другий вентилятор витягує з будинку використане повітря.
І обмін тепловою енергією між потоками відбувається у цьому пристрої.
Для підігріву свіжого повітря використовується
до 80% власного тепла кімнат будинку.
Тож додатково треба опалити лише цю невелику різницю.
20%  нестачі тепла для будинку
компенсує тепловий насос.
Ця система використовує як джерело тепла ґрунт.
На глибині 32 метри закопані труби з теплоносієм,
який підігрівається теплом землі і передає його далі трубам з водою.
Ті ж підключені до системи підігріву підлоги
у кожному помешканні.
Ну що ж, подивимось, як тут живеться студентам.
- Привіт, мене звати Михайло, Дойче Веллє.
- Стелла.
-Стелла, я тут впізнав у тебе Тиранозавра рекса.
Ви - палеонтологиня?
- Дійсно,  я вивчаю геологію
з фокусом на палеонтологію.
Ось через такі забірні клапани відводиться повітря з кухні і ванної кімнати.
Одночасно ззовні ось цим припливним повітропроводом
подається підігріте свіже повітря.
Термостатом Стелла регулює опалення підлоги.
У кімната площею 26 квадратних метрів
тепло і затишно.
Я в абсолютному захваті. З одного боку, тут відмінна якість повітря.
І на кухні, і у ванній жодних проблем з вологою.
Температура мені підходить.
Навіть зараз, узимку, мені радше доводиться відкривати двері на балкон,
щоб було прохолодніше, ніж вмикати опалення.
Проживання в такій одномісній кімнаті коштує 560 євро на місяць.
Це фіксована сума.
Будинок сам виробляє струм завдяки сонячним батареям, тож комунальних доплат немає.
А зараз я витягаю фільтр фінальної очистки.
Ось такі фільтри стоять тут у системі обміну повітрям.
Чуєте цей звук? Це працює насос системи, яка збирає дощову воду,
і ця вода у будівлі використовується лише для змиву у туалетах.
Будинок, який сам себе забезпечує електрикою, теплом і водою.
Такі будинки ще називають "пасивними",
бо вони незалежні від центральної електромережі і опалення,
а трапляється, і самі віддають надлишковий струм у мережу міста.
Кай Кюнцель, який підвозить мене на роботу на електроавтівці, розповідає,
що у нього є вже кілька приватних замовлень на такі енергоефективні будинки.
Архітектор сповідує ідею, що проект будинку,
підбір будівельних матеріалів і екологічне опалення,
необхідно споглядати як єдину, цілісну, дружню до довкілля систему.
Друзі, пишіть у коментарях, що ще вам цікаво знати про Німеччину.
Побачимось!